-Hey, I have to talk to
you about something,
because there's been some
headlines about you
last couple of days.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
-Yeah. It's
really stressing me out.
-Well, your fans are upset
because, apparently,
everyone's broken-hearted that
the gap in your teeth
is not there anymore.
And fans are heartbroken.
People are upset.
No one knows what to say.
What is going on?
What -- The gap is gone?
What's up?
-Yeah. Well, first of all,
the fact that this is
a newsworthy event
in our world right now
is pretty Chaka Khan to me
-Chaka Khan.
-Yeah, why is everyone upset
-Well, so I had a permanen
retainer since I was like 13
and it was just glued
to the back of my teeth.
And I was having a lot of
neck problems recently,
so my orthodontist --
she decided that it would be
a good idea to take it off and
see if my jaw sort of expanded
And it helped me,
and my gap closed by itself.
And I'm really
sad about it, too.
-Now, wait, wait.
Hold on a second.
First of all,
you got to walk me back.
Your neck bothered you,
and so that's what made yo
take the retainer
out of your mouth?
Like, is that a thing?
Has anyone ever heard of that?
-Yeah. That is a real thing.
Yeah.
-So if your neck bothers you
it might be your teeth?
-Well, as you grow
as a human being, your...
-Uh-huh.
-...your skull expands and
your jaw and your teeth move
You know, your teeth
don't look like they did
when you were a baby.
-They do, actually.
I was born...
I was born with veneers.
-Oh. Cool. Cool.
-I broke this tooth.
This one is fake.
-Let me feel it.
-It's not going to
feel different.
It feels like a tooth.
-Not if you go like this.
Can you hear that?
-It sounds like a tooth.
-It's like when knock on a
hollow part of a wall.
-Is that one fake, too?
-Are they both fake?
-All my teeth are fake.
Yeah, actually.
This one might be fake, as well.
Yeah. That's weird.
-Yeah.
-But let me tap on your tooth.
-Okay.
-You don't have any nails.
-Yeah. I don't have any nails.
I know.
I took them off before the show.
I want to talk to you --
-Anyway, hold on.
This is really important.
-Yeah.
-I'm sad about my
gap tooth, too.
So I'd really appreciate som
privacy in this time --
-Wait. What?
First of all, don't demand -
don't demand --
Don't clap for that.
Don't demand or clap.
You demand some privacy?
-Yeah.
-I think it looks beautiful.
-Well, I have to deal with
a whole new world of problems.
-No.
-Getting food stuck in my tooth.
-That's your new thing?
-Yeah, because before, it woul
just slide right through.
-So your whole life has changed,
and you're dealing with
it, as well.
-Yeah.
-Just as much as the public an
your fans are dealing with -
-Yeah, but it's
going to come back.
-The gap will come back?
-Yeah.
-How?
-Other retainers.
-So you're gonna get a retaine
to split your tooth --
-The world of dentistry
is so advanced --
-Wait. Are you serious
about this?
Because, what if --
Dude, what if you come back,
you get a gap,
and then your neck hurts?
Then what? Then where do we go
Back to the drawing board.
-No, because we're gonna
do it in a really
holistic, sort of, like,
osteopath--
-Don't even talk to me
about this.
Hey, I do want to -- I have
story I want to bring up.
And I don't even
want to talk about it.
But I heard this rumor that yo
used to make reservations
at a dinner -- dinner
reservations at a restaurant
under a famous person's name
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
-Mm-hmm, yeah.
-You used to call up and say you
have a table for George Clooney.
-Yeah.
-Why?
-Because I wanted to go to
the good restaurants
when I was growing --
when I was in high school.
-Do you know George Clooney?
-No, I don't.
-So, wait.
You would call up and go,
"Hey, table for four,
George Clooney"?
-Yeah, 'cause nobody else
is named George Clooney.
Also, it works every time.
Try it.
-I should actually try, yeah
-Next time you can't get int
a restaurant --
-I can't get into
any restaurant, yeah.
-But I used to do that
when I was a teenager.
-And you'd call
up and say George --
And then what would happen
when you'd show up?
-I'd say, "He's going to
join us later."
It'd be, like, a bunch of kids
-Does George know
that you do this?
-Well, I met him
a couple of years ago.
We were traveling to
the Toronto Film Festival
and we happened to be
on the same plane.
And I was like,
"Hi. I'm Dakota."
And he's like,
"Oh, I've heard of you.
I know what you do."
-"I know what you do,"
is what he said?
-Yeah. He was like,
"You call and you use my name.
It's okay."
-He really did that?
-Yeah.
-So he said it's okay?
-So you continued to do it
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Why not?
I think it's fun.
-All the time.
-Let's talk about your movie
"The Peanut Butter Falcon.
-Yeah.
-Tell me about this.
And what is the movie about,
for anyone watching.
-"The Peanut Butter Falcon
is about a young man
with down syndrome
who escapes a nursing home
to fulfill his dream of becoming
a professional wrestler.
-And is this --
Who is the actor?
-His name is Zack Gottsagen.
-It was his first film,
is that correct?
-It was his first
feature film, yeah.
He had made one kind of
smaller film before.
-Did you get to --
It's him and Shia, right?
-Him and Shia LaBeouf.
-Shia LaBeouf.
-Yeah, the other Shia.
-Is there two Shias?
-No.
That's the name I use to get
reservations, by the way.
-Yeah.
-Table for two, Shia LaBeouf
How was it working with Shia
He's a little...
He's a little reckless
a little bit, wasn't he?
-I think that, sometimes,
on occasion,
he can be a little reckless.
However, on this film, Zack, who
is the other star of the film,
is a really incredible person.
He's the most pure and lovin
and genuine, nonjudgmental
human being I've ever met
in my life.
And he totally changed my worl
and totally changed Shia's
world, too.
And the three of us became
really close.
They became very, very close
And it kind of totally shifted
things for Shia, I think.
-Oh, good.